this last one was better by a guy you've
already talked about before namely see
app it's key see now we know what the
MXC Pinsky so far which is that knee has
what kind of shape a triangle very good
see this like squares so v3 future may
be a bit of a cube stuff and I wanted to
buy it up bleh
you know if my two-dimensional space I
want to see if I could divide up into
another way how about triangles okay so
this one is a bit tricky I need to help
myself this one stays away did you start
with one space okay though is obvious
way to divide this up into triangles is
just to go right down the middle okay
now what I've got is I've got now two
different places within the space that I
need to go visit okay that's not very
hard you just go like so nothing to it
okay because triangles when you divide
up you only get two right and the next
I'm going to get four and then eight as
opposed to here you grow a lot faster
right we went from 4 to 16 to 64 pretty
rapidly right because I'm quarter in
each time the piano curve grows even
faster right we went from nine to 27 we
didn't even bother drawing 81 sorry
anyone anyone we did anyone but the next
one would be hydrated for a lot this one
grows a lot slower so let's have a look
at this next one this is already the
subdivision that exists okay so I'll
just make triangles but the whole idea
now is out of each of these triangles
are going to make a new pair of
triangles right so you divide them up
like this okay
now put your pencils down for a second
if you're still trying to finish the
previous curve because you're really
gonna watch this okay remember by order
here right
from one so I still have to finish this
entire triangle that's here before I
finish this train before I go on to this
train right so I'm gonna do these two
then do these two okay now see if it's
keep cooking they're out of human sports
he said okay it's not that hard
this problem is exactly the same as the
first one that you did except the only
difference is they're triangles as
scared instead of squares do you see
that
it's just four triangles jammed together
in exactly the same way but watch if I
put these in place you'll see you see
that's that's the hilbert curve right
once you make those triangles squares
you should go one two three they go it's
the same curve so far okay now let me
get rid of this and this is very much
not the Hilda curve as you see what is
the logical next step logical next step
well the moral is okay now we're gonna
take the existing subdivision right
which is like this now let's get that
order down so that we know this right
one two I'm going one two three every
triangle here is going to be half into
another pair of trainers all right so
for instance if I have this triangle to
get two triangles there's my two you see
that by doing this one that's the second
one
I'll get 2 and then another 2 ok and
remember your order right I've got to
finish this triangle first and then I'm
going to do that in this train so here
is triangle one you see it to sim card
up so where shall I go remembering that
I want to go that way I'm guessing I do
this
yeah there's triangle one for you is
triangle check these triangle that's
sorry
there's triangle sweet that was just get
it to try at you now I've done triangle
too
I need to get into triangle three I need
to cross triangle 3 into 4 and then I'm
finished okay now that's such a good
question right what you have a look at
this right it does seem like I'm going
towards a circle like you know I'm
getting more little signs right we just
follow with me ok watch this this is the
step that blows blows blinds ok you blew
my mind when I was trying to make it
work ok when you go whatever you do the
next iteration ok you start with the
previous one which currently looks like
this you start with the previous
iteration and then you divide it up in
such a way so that you can copy whatever
shape you have here into here alright
now just for a second right see all of
my triangles that I think what kinds of
triangles on it they are all right
angled triangles all right so if I were
to go towards having a circle for
instance a division I might make is one
like this thank you see that because
then I would go around every no one here
now I just I just go all the way around
ok but this subdivision doesn't work at
least it doesn't work in a fractal sense
because look at the 40 triangles I've
made right only two of them are right
angled ok that's the first problem
the second problem is even the right
agent ones these guys they are no longer
similar to any of the other right-angled
triangles they're not just right on your
training list what kind of right angle
triangles are there to each other to
each other look this is a square right
1 2 3 4 there isosceles why don't you
try and love's right
these are right angle but they don't
like sauce to it so I have to abandon
this skis this is a little bit like
going the wrong way around the hilbert
curve you get a difference
Viveca it's just not this one so how
this how we divide this up properly
let's get up order down here so I went
one two three four five six seven eight
okay just look at triangle one there it
is right there how do I divide them up
so I get something similar
yeah I'm gonna go across yeah okay now
it doesn't take that much imagination to
see I'm gonna do that for all of the
triangles all the eight triangles like
this is the pattern I'm going to get you
see that you see how all the train was
I've got they're still isosceles there's
still right-angled everything is fine
all right let's have a look it up order
okay this is the first triangle I have
to complete I'm going to begin yeah I've
got to finish this triangle before I
move on to the next triangle
all right and I'm going up yeah I'm
going here all right
I've finished I finished triangle one
they aren't you got two triangle to
finish triangle two before you move up
to three
damnit
okay now remember we started with
something that bore resemblance to the
hilbert curve right then it stopped
looking like curve and then it's
something completely different we ought
to the one two three fourth iteration
we're going to go up to the fire
so let's have a look at this let's see
if we can finish it off right I've put
in my stand end points and you can see
I've done that so you can see the scale
symmetry every time it's just stagnating
points get closer and closer and closer
together at the corners okay now if I
need to finish this you can see right I
need to finish this triangle to the
first one right and then I need to get
over into this triangle over here so I
cross and then I finished the triangle
right then I need to go up to finish
this triangle go across and you're
getting for this kind of shape right now
by the time you get to here you've
almost got something which you can just
do by symmetry you can start to stop
thinking about it so much and you come
across ah and you get this odd tangle
kind of shape which you ought to
recognize from the third iteration right
so this is advantage of fractal design
every time you go down a level you
gather the previous levels by copy right
and where am i I've got to go ahead okay
here we go
do it properly by the way do you notice
just before we leave off this right G
notice how number three and number five
look more similar to each other then
like say four and five right there's
this kind of flipping back and forth
you're gonna see that as I draw the last
one and then you can take the pictures
okay so watch me